Garrett is with us in Texas I Garrett
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you I appreciate it what's going on how
are you gonna make a brother how can I
help
alright so I've recently just turned 22
on Sunday I got a kind of interesting
story I guess you could say I sell cars
for a living I work for Ford here in
Austin and last year was my first year
into the business I made 55,000 but
whenever I was in high school my dad
started this business underneath my name
why so I haven't filed taxes or anything
like that
stop stop stop why your father put his
business in a high school kids name then
I'm not sure so he started to selling I
guess we'll just say items on eBay
and he got banned off eBay with his
account his name under his social and
all this stuff so he asked me to create
a PayPal account for me I didn't know
what it was of what you know I was young
he just said make it he's my dad along
so I did it so I made the account
everything and he need to manage the
account and he he stored the items and
stuff at the house sold the products for
three years and here recently he had
quit but I got this letter in the mail
from the IRS and I had to file taxes for
three years and you know I never really
made a substantial income or anything
like that I went to college you know
whenever to play football for a year and
I got like 10,000 and student loans I
still have to pay actually bad all taxes
on these transactions no because it's
been mining I don't know because he's
just gone okay well yeah so the business
for the 2017 they did what was they did
27,000 and sales gross sales so I don't
know what how much of it he can write
off or anything like that in 2018 he did
a hundred and twelve thousand and then
on 2019 he did like a hundred and eight
it's roughly a quarter million dollars
between the three years just in gross
sales now how much on that I can write
off or you know whatever I don't know I
talked to a CPA that I was referred to
in the Dallas area they said it would be
about 900
dollars to get the taxes filed and all
that stuff I've been trying to get them
filed since last year with him but he
won't sit down with me to figure out
what I can ride off and what I can and
I've been asked to cpa if i should just
write off or not or just follow my
regular income taxes with the company
from forward and she told me to know
that would mess it up we need to start
from 2017 to file those years first
because then the IRS will just no more
letters exactly
so just that advice was correct and the
$900 you're spending is what you're
doing to do immediately what you're
going to happen I'm pretty aggravated
with your dad right now I have to say
that what kind of father does this kind
of stuff to his own son not basically
great in the film do what basically
raised myself like my mom's in prison so
I've never had like a mother to talk to
I said that abused me and my dad's like
a gambling problem and alcohol like that
kind of stuff so I'm sorry well it you
know what the item he was selling is
right I do but I don't know if it's
appropriate for the show that's fine I
don't that you don't need to do that
that's not the point
though which is also not surprising the
but what we what you can do is we sit
down with your CPA and you're gonna have
to file a return based on what you think
your cost of goods sold was meaning you
got a quarter million dollars in gross
sales but every one of those items he
paid something for them okay then he
brought up in China on the Aliexpress
store I know where he bought it I don't
know how to get that order it's got your
name on it
the Aliexpress it's like a different
account he used a PayPal card or a debit
card or something that's in his need to
pay for Oh in his name that to purchase
the orders yeah so every transaction and
everything that went through ebay is in
my name I understand okay so what you've
got to do is get the best information
you can get ahold of to make the best
guess as to what he paid for the items
my guess is that he wasn't making a that
there's nowhere near $250,000 profit
here there's probably there there might
be 30 or $40,000 profit here when
everything's said and done so what'd you
ever talk to him last year he said about
60% let's drop it okay well uh what I
would do is guess if you can't get real
information other than off the top of
his head one thing we know whatever he
says is he's full of crap we can't
believe it
and so you've got to look and actually
do some research as if you were going to
reopen this business and find out what
you would be paying for these items and
then reconstruct a business profit and
loss statement with your CPAs help and
it's a guess but that'll help you file
if you get audited that's when you got a
real problem because you don't have real
records but you're just gonna guess
and you're gonna guess I as to the
expenses to write off as much as like
you know exactly to have as little
profit as possible to keep from paying
more taxes than you have to on the
income your father used in your name and
stole from you okay because that's
effectively what's gone on here this is
gonna cost you tax money to keep to keep
straight with the IRS because the
problem is your Social Security's out
there doing stuff okay now yeah the last
thing is this you need to have a
conversation with him that sounds like
this never use my name never use my
social security number again ever for
anything or I will file a police report
for identity theft it needs to sound
just like that it's gonna piss him off
and I really don't care and I currently
live with him because I'm trying to save
money to separate you you need to move I
mean I did move to Georgetown and just
the rent and everything because I
literally make about forty five hundred
gross I just I couldn't save anything so
I wanna i want to buy a duplex i want to
listen to you
not justify anything you're doing to
continue to stay in that household this
is a messed up situation he cannot use
your name anymore and you've got to get
some physical distance from him I hope
someday you can repair and have some
kind of a relationship at some level but
today your father has stolen twenty or
thirty thousand dollars from you and
stolen your identity you cannot continue
in this path because it's not gonna stop
man it's gonna happen again and again
and again and again and again he's a
financial abuser and you've got to
separate yourself from him as soon as
possible I'm sorry I'm sorry you're
going through this and and listen man
find you a good church and get plugged
in and get hooked up with a good pastor
to walk with you cuz you're entering
manhood on a rocky road and you you're a
good man you got good places you can go
you don't have to be this way you don't
have to be like him